foreign
hi guys and welcome to another Super
cult production of congratulations
[Music]
I've got a great announcement man
um I'm on tour I added more tours More
tour more dates and uh I am going to be
in different cities uh we've got a bunch
of different cities coming up that don't
push me tour I'm calling it starts next
year and uh we've got uh some what do
you call it we've got San Diego out
there it's it's on sale now if you're if
you're on my patreon you can use the
pre-sale don't push me if you're
listening to this on Wednesday if not on
Thursday it's open to the general public
so uh general public we got Raleigh
North Carolina Savannah Georgia
Tempe Arizona Denver Colorado Cheyenne
Wyoming uh Boston Massachusetts some
Hollywood dates in there just at the
club Albany New York uh Lakeland Florida
Jacksonville Florida and then next year
which is the thing I just announced uh
is San Diego Portland Oregon Seattle
Washington San Antonio Texas Sugar Land
Texas I've never been there New Orleans
been there a few times Providence Rhode
Island
uh New York New York New York New York
we're doing a Beacon Theater uh Chicago
Illinois Chicago theater and Springfield
Missouri uh and then Midland Texas
worst name for a place ever Midland
um especially now with everyone saying
everything is mid
you'll just post an Instagram picture
and then somebody will just write mid
okay uh you know what what can we do win
some you win some you lose some and some
of them are just mid
um so yeah go get tickets right now the
good seats are filling up
uh they might have filled up already I
don't know because I'm doing this a few
days before I'm actually posting it so
I'll let you you know we'll see go look
at the [ __ ] seating Maps um but yeah
I just did you can also get your merch
there and Sport it on the the tour
exclusive merch is awesome man I've been
on tour being go to chrisley.com and get
merch uh and the tour exclusive merch
has been [ __ ] awesome
um we were in where were we Peoria and
then Rockford Illinois
um and Rockford Illinois
I sort of got all that comes all it
comes down to is if a place has a coffee
shop near where I'm staying then I just
I like the place period that's how it
goes there was a literal coffee shop
connected to the hotel I stayed to in
Rockford and I was like this place is
[ __ ] amazing and it was so much
better than than Peoria only because of
that both of the places you know look a
lot of murders in both look let's just
let's just face facts a lot of murderers
a lot of murders in both of them we
stayed on a [ __ ] lake or a river
whatever it was a lot of bodies in there
in Rockford okay but Rockford seemed
great because it had a [ __ ] can very
nice coffee place attached to the hotel
so we're in business
um did Peoria people think it's a good
comedy town because Richard Pryor was
born there really is not relevant at all
all good
um the theater was cool look Peoria
everyone was great there at the theater
everyone was great Rockford Illinois but
uh Peoria literally uh there's just
there was nothing to do there was
nothing to do and I was there for a
little bit but I also watched videos on
YouTube about like Peoria you know I do
my research dude I [ __ ] I'm at the
point now where I'm 42 and I just
straight up look at YouTube videos of
cities I'm gonna be going to
it's the most [ __ ] dad [ __ ] of all
time and I did it and it said Puri and
Rockford uh well it said Rockford the
violence forget it and Peoria uh a lot
of property crime and all that [ __ ] but
it's all good we did there nobody robbed
[ __ ] or killed me so
um
yeah I you know
man I can't believe the F you know what
it was though when I got to Peoria it
was the and then especially Rockford it
was a beautiful day but the the the the
first day Peoria it was the first day
this year where I just [ __ ] walked
outside uh I I I I I I walked outside
the day after we got there we got there
the day before then the day of the show
I walked outside and breathed in that
crisp air and just beautiful wind of
just and nice nice enough day little bit
overcast partly cloudy it was partly
cloudy in Peoria and it just felt
[ __ ] so nice dude
and what does it feel like when we feel
that first [ __ ] cold breeze of the
Fall what does it feel like
why does it feel nostalgic
I said it to my wife
my beautiful angel wife hey why does it
feel nostalgic when the cold comes does
it feel nostalgic for you and she goes
like this yeah why and I said why is
that she said probably because we both
grew up on the east coast and I said
yeah but it's just because we used to
feel this and now we don't anymore in
Los Angeles
and she was like yeah I like you know I
like to call it boss Angelus but I said
Los Angeles and she was like yeah and I
was like maybe you're right I don't know
but I [ __ ] am brought back to when I
was a child and it feels nice because I
had a good childhood but also am I
blocking out bad things that happened
who knew
because it also there's a tinge of
sadness what's that all about huh hey
what's up sadness under happiness
what's going on what's going on I'm
happy but also what's going on tinja
sadness
what's going on sad
oh hey I'm right here just to let you
know oh hey what's up sadness okay well
I guess I'm happy
that first Breeze that first Cool Breeze
of the Fall just
and you're just walking on sunshine oh
and then that first Breeze just under
your shirt
and then
what's up sadness Gunk just right here
what's that all about
thanks for thanks for visiting me in
Peoria
Rockford it was there too then I got
home in La first cold day
sadness is there to stay yes nice we
talk about seasonal depression in in
life and that's a real thing are we all
just [ __ ] or is it a real thing what
does it matter if I feel it if it's
psychosomatic attic insane what does it
matter if I feel it
God family
attic insane dude
you know
act insane act insane
um
Every Time I Think of Peoria I think of
The Little Shop of Horrors where they go
and Peoria
New York dude and if you can make it in
[ __ ] Peoria they say that you can
make it you're in you made it anywhere
so [ __ ] yeah dude made it made it again
dude [ __ ] yeah I made it dude
I can make it in Peoria and New York we
got the New York tickets on sale
February 18th we got New York Beacon
Theater New York playing a Beacon
Theater February 18th and they're
playing in Chicago we go to Chicago
so
um anyway the sadness is right there
right behind the happiness and uh and we
all trudge through my babies we all
trudge through don't we people come up
to me after shows I do the meet and
greet and they say yeah I've been
through a really hard time and your
stuff lifts me up and dude you know what
I'll be Josh Groban to you [ __ ]
okay I will raise you up man I used to
shy to that and be like oh please not
enough but please enough enough enough
you don't need to be all you know
sentimental and I feel bad and oh that's
nothing and uh you know you dude I'm
happy to be here for you how about that
I am happy to be here for you
if you're listening to this podcast and
you had a shitty day and you were
looking forward to this podcast to turn
it on so you could get some [ __ ]
yucks I am happy to be here for you
because I know you feel the [ __ ]
sadness behind the happiness too
sometimes and I am happy to be here for
you whether you're in Peoria
or New York but he's [ __ ] nice with
it dude he's absolutely nice with it he
can sing and at a insane dude
he's absolutely nice with it
so come see me that don't push me tour
and uh God damn we had a good time in
Peoria for some reason Adam Ray came
with me a hilarious comedian Mike La
Noche came with me a hilarious comedian
we just had a ball dude
[ __ ] Adam Ray's got this Dr Phil
impression that makes me [ __ ] laugh
dude
go to go check it out on YouTube or
something probably but
um yeah dude it was really nice the cold
breezes here and I guess I'm happy dude
you know it's like it's really kind of
annoying to me here comes my hater [ __ ]
dude and I don't mean to be a hater and
sometimes I'm not a a hater I'm just
speaking facts right fax
um
I don't like when people you know it's
like the whole there it's that time
again where the breeze all that [ __ ]
chick a white chick especially needs a
white chick with like a vest like a
brown vest and a white sweater under it
all she all she needs is that [ __ ]
that first Breeze and she goes get the
brown vest get it get it get it get it
get it get the [ __ ] the yarned up
sweater where that goes over my you know
how much do [ __ ] chicks love just
having it so they can't even barely they
use they scoop up the [ __ ] ends of
the uh sleeves and they're just like
this you know what I mean oh did you
feel that that's what the collective ooh
did you feel that on the first sh under
the shirt get the vest oh did you feel
that
it just moves from east to west as as
the because you know it gets warmer and
oh did you feel did you would you feel
that would you feel the difference
would you feel that by the end in San
Diego
dude it's just it sweeps up off the
Atlantic in Atlantic City
of Tennessee
[ __ ] Nebraska what are the [ __ ] in
the middle there who knows
and then [ __ ] all the way to San
Diego did you feel that yeah
get the get the Brown Band
like it's like a horror movie what is
this
oh
from the makers
of oh did you feel that comes Brown vest
a Netflix movie with you know even
though it's about white chicks we also
have a bunch of other [ __ ] colors in
it too and you won't be able to tell
anyone's sexuality Netflix
oh did you feel that
um
so yeah um I don't even really honestly
know what I was talking about I just
kind of lost track then it's all good
because that's what we do we [ __ ] fly
by fly by the seat of our pants and
that's what we do in this podcast since
the only podcast that'll [ __ ] do it
to you it's the only podcast that'll do
it to you I see other [ __ ] have
notepads your boy don't have any
notepads man I know [ __ ] they
seem to be [ __ ] stream of
Consciousness but let me tell you
something dude I'm the stream of
conscious dude okay I haven't looked at
a note yet dude
all I did was [ __ ] and I'm not that's
not a brag or a flex I'm just saying
dude I respect you enough to be truly me
I expect you enough to be truly me now
when I say truly it truly is the [ __ ]
drink right with the [ __ ] now when I
say truly it makes me think of the
[ __ ] trulies that everyone drank in
my [ __ ] hotel room and then left them
open and then when they left and then we
woke up the next day in Peoria [ __ ]
whole room smelled like a goddamn
pomegranate and it's okay my baby's dude
it's all good man he wakes up and he
smells pomegranates right under his nose
because of the trulies and it's all good
dude he's got that crisp Breeze and the
sadness behind the [ __ ] happiness and
he smells a goddamn pomegranate in the
middle of [ __ ] Peoria and it's all
good my babies
Calvin came with me Kristen came with me
uh Calvin's absolutely killing it he's
getting tall and uh
man you know it's one good thing one
good thing about like traveling like
this is you know Calvin's growing up in
Los Angeles I guess I guess I mean we're
building a house like I said and we're
gonna be [ __ ] moving a little bit out
30 minutes out but
you know Calvin grows up in uh Los
Angeles and
um
it's hell on Earth or whatever you know
because like you can just drive a few
blocks right until you see something
dodgy right
you could drive you could go a few
blocks before you see something dodgy
now let's face facts so we're moving and
it's all good but I don't know about
Calvin growing up in proper LA right now
we're gonna go to the [ __ ] San
Bernardino Valley
uh whatever it's in Bernardino Valley
you know in the 1980s and 90s San
Bernardino Valley was the murder capital
of California
uh and I know that because I was
watching [ __ ] City YouTube videos of
cities so and to Dad and it's all good
but I was watching that and then I was
watching uh
uh I'll get to that later but yeah so
we're
you know Calvin's growing up in um Los
Angeles and it's uh you know it's a bit
of a [ __ ] thing because the second
anyone is like okay but what are your
pronouns to him like when he's [ __ ]
he hasn't thrown a football yet or some
[ __ ] or have it hasn't even thought of
any real life issue oh your boy's gonna
go ballistic
and it's all good well I don't want to
miss gen the second someone says I don't
want to misgender you and my and my son
has only taken about 350
000 steps and that's it I'm gonna go
ballistic
if you're asking someone their pronouns
at [ __ ] 150 000 steps your boy goes
ballistic
and if it's blood he goes even more
ballistic
so um yeah if you do that to my son so
we're moving out to uh a little bit of a
different area and um but anyway that
that I digress because I was talking
about it's nice to go on tour with
Calvin because he gets to see like
[ __ ] trees with red leaves on him you
know Los Angeles two kinds of trees
trees and then [ __ ] trees with no
leaves okay there's just trees with some
leaves and trees with no leaves but if
you go to [ __ ] back when the white
woman originally said do you feel that
red trees Orange you got bright yellow
shits right right before all the the
fall turns and all the treat the leaves
go down and hit the pile where some kids
hiding and they get creamed by [ __ ]
garbage trucks right that's what used to
happen when we were in you always heard
that urban legend about like don't lay
in the leaves a garbage truck could come
cream ya
and um
so we so so yeah so he's out in like
Rockford Illinois now of course bang
bang shoot him up he might get his wig
pushed back but it's a small wig he's
small so the bullets probably won't hit
him okay they'll probably honestly hit
me
anyway we were hanging out near the
[ __ ] uh
lake or river Ravine or I don't know
what you call it because I'm a city boy
but um
yeah so and I was like of course there's
bodies in that wherever that body of
water is but he was looking at the geese
not the bodies and so but he was playing
and he was like he went out for a it was
a beautiful lesson I learned because he
was running to this uh well I guess it
was an abandoned parking lot it looked
like a [ __ ] State pin but uh he
starts running towards it and gets
smaller and it's already small but he's
getting smaller and smaller or not like
Calvin and he turns around I say come
here and he runs back towards me a
little bit and then stops and then
Kristen's like let him go explore it's
good for him you know and I was like
yeah you're right don't say come here
just follow him and I was like you're
right so he went all the way over to
that [ __ ] abandoned parking structure
and I ran
and I walked after him I was like
following him following him like I'm a
[ __ ] jaguar or some [ __ ]
like it's the movie beast and he's Idris
Elba
and I'm just I'm just like tracking him
like I'm Bear Grylls and he's a trout
and so um
and it was kind of nice though man I was
just watching him and I saw him get so
far into the distance and then he just
[ __ ] came back and I was like were
you exploring it and he goes yes
I was cute as [ __ ] man
um
so yeah so that's so it's nice to be
able to travel and go to these places
because I'm gonna go to I'm gonna hit
some cold places dude I mean I'm gonna
be in Chicago and New York in February
okay and if you thought that was it I'm
gonna be in Providence Rhode Island in
February okay
gotta get the cold days because Cove had
[ __ ] everything up and it's hard to
get a Saturday to perform in because
everyone everyone not only just you know
uh
comedians also singers
and musicians and also magicians are
getting all all the [ __ ] venues so
you know there's a lot of theater acts
now nowadays so
um it is what it is you know uh but yeah
man I'm really grateful and uh we'll be
loving it we'd be clubbing
um
we'll be clubbing remember that song
from Ice Cube we be clubbing don't visit
nothing wrong get your Club home he he
honestly I wanna I think rappers are the
ultimate when they finally get to the
like they start selling like a white dad
you know like if if Ice Cube rap that
song we be clubbing and he was a white
dad just like [ __ ] with just a
T-shirt and like some jeans on everyone
will be like this is the whitest song of
all time you know we just give these
rappers passes just because they came
out of Straight Out of Compton he went
hard with that [ __ ] we'd be clubbing
dude
thank you
you know what I'm saying
somebody needs to get [ __ ] Kanye West
some help dude I mean I know I feel like
I talk about this guy every [ __ ]
podcast but it's just like they kicked
him off of Instagram
and it's like well because he's [ __ ]
being anti-semitic and I get it you know
I think they should kick everyone off
into I think they should kick everyone
off of every platform
and just have splintered platforms of
like like what was that one um
parlor like let them just be there they
want it they want that let them have
that let them let the people who want
the freest as [ __ ] dude not everybody
wants free speech on Twitter people
think they want free speech until a
[ __ ] comes after them you know
like I what I don't get is Kanye knows
the rules he knows the rules he knows if
you're anti-semitic can get kicked off
did he get kicked off to Twitter by the
way
you got kicked off of Twitter too no no
not Twitter okay
so he says how are you gonna kick me off
of Instagram you used to be my n-word
and then he tweeted this picture of him
and Mark Zuckerberg and Mark Zuckerberg
has the microphone you know
and uh but it's sad because uh he needs
help right how about that that's all
that's where it stops when you need
somebody when someone needs help just
get them help kick them off everything
get him help did he get kicked off of
Twitter too
no
he did but now he's back on they just
they let you they give you a timeout for
a little bit
they give them a they give them a
timeout for a little bit they go what'd
you say about you because you can't [ __ ]
with did you don't [ __ ] with the Jews
like the fact that I'm even talking
about it right now this podcast I'll
probably be Shadow band
yeah Jews are killing it we love the
Jews
um we love the Jews and we love blacks
and we love whites we love them all
um and we love you know what I mean we
love we love [ __ ] trans
people and people who are short and tall
and all sorts of [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
guys I love better help all right
um I struggle with uh solving problems
Within Myself I struggle with solving
problems day to day and it can be tough
to train your brain to stay in problem
solving mode you know when faced with a
challenge in life a lot of times the
thoughts become little by little and
then it's like a big Avalanche of
thought and you just need to sit down
and for me it's hard for me to do my day
because of these thoughts but when you
learn how to find your own Solutions
there's no better feeling a therapist
can help you become a better Problem
Solver making it easier to accomplish
your goals no matter how big or small
and I use therapy and because of that
this struggle has been greatly
diminished it is a beautiful thing and I
am such a proponent of therapy and
better help is the perfect way to do
this
um if you're thinking of giving therapy
a try yeah better help is a great option
it's convenient it's accessible
affordable and it's also entirely online
so you don't have to battle traffic
um or even leave your house which is
amazing you get matched with a therapist
after filling out a brief survey and uh
the cool thing is you can switch
therapists at any time uh it's very easy
so when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
congratulations today to get 10 off your
first month
it's a deal for my listeners go to
betterhelp.com
congratulations thanks
[Music]
saw that I saw the new Hellraiser which
is like um
I saw the new hell rate dude I [ __ ]
did it you know me and my OCD dude me
and my [ __ ] obsessive [ __ ] I watched
the new Hellraiser and then what did I
do if you know me and you're a real fan
what did I do dude if this is a
crystalia game show I saw the new
Hellraiser and then what did crystalia
do a
start watching all of them from the
beginning or B went to bed
if you guessed hey yay dude I started
watching the first one and I just go man
it's like because I've watched the
[ __ ] end the new one on Hulu okay
I've never seen a Hellraiser before
and uh well I used to love that Tupac
song mama is a Hellraiser
so I watched the Hellraisers uh new one
and I'm like okay all right right
all right okay so these guys can't tell
the difference between Pleasure and Pain
okay
and he thought he wanted to [ __ ] he
thought he wanted to you know he thought
he wanted to have
what happens is when you [ __ ] move
the block around in the right direction
you get to pick what you want to be your
Ultimate Fantasy and you can be Pat it
could be power love Resurrection or
sensation or two other ones it's there's
six choices I don't know and they call
them like Leviathan [ __ ] Leviticus
and all the shits I don't know what it
is but
begin with Alan
the guy picked Sensations and yeah
[ __ ] like a clock went in the middle
of his chest and it started making him
feel Sensations and he didn't realize
that to these cenobites who are [ __ ]
Jesus I sound like a [ __ ] dork
what he didn't realize is to the
cenobites okay okay uh Pleasure and Pain
is actually the same thing and sensation
you know they can't tell the difference
between Pleasure and Pain so it just
makes me laugh so the guy thought he was
going to have like complete orgasms but
it just makes him laughs because instead
you know they just put a bunch of
strings and um
and like [ __ ] this contraption in his
chest and they would pull on it and
we're gonna make him feel pain every few
minutes and this makes me laugh he
thought he's going to be [ __ ]
absolutely busting
um so
anyway I watched it and I was like okay
okay okay
all right
I'll watch the [ __ ] for okay it ended
and I go like this fine dude I'll watch
the original
oh what okay you got me dude
s m Blood and Guts and Gore
all right you win the universe I'll stay
seated and go all the way to the
beginning
so I turned on the original Hellraiser
all right now before I did that what did
he do did he a
make popcorn or B
Google the ins and outs of every
Hellraiser movie and also uh find out
which Hellraiser movies were the best
and people explaining the movie
Hellraiser in depth and reading a bunch
of different articles about that if you
guess B yeah hey dude Chris doesn't make
popcorn because it takes time and he
wants to eat stuff immediately so we
need stuff like pretzels and ice cream
that's already pre-made yay yay dude
when he's really hungry he gets [ __ ]
pissed off because he has to make a
sandwich yay dude he'd rather just
[ __ ] eat something that's pre-made
yay
yay B the entrance B worst cake Joe of
all time so
you God
Crest and so
um
wow imagine if you had it I should have
that game show so anyway the answer was
B and so [ __ ]
on our show today the answer went a and
then B and then so I read everything and
then I watched it I was like all right
all right you really wet my appetite
articles
you really I went Miami really you're
really wetting my fangoria appetite
articles
so
um
so I did it so I watched the [ __ ] I
started watching the beginning I watched
25 minutes
her eyelids got heavy
so what did he do dude how well do you
know crystallia did he a go directly to
bed or B watch another thing that wasn't
so [ __ ] demonic so he could clear it
and then get into a better mood and then
go to bed
if you guess me you get it you
God
Crest worst game show so so
I did I turned on a little thing and I
went to bed and then I woke up and I
[ __ ] finished it dude now finishing a
movie like Hellraiser in the morning
[ __ ] up your day nice to meet you day
okay we're [ __ ] up good catch you
later
now I watched it dude now granted you
got to understand in the 80s the
graphics and the [ __ ] uh special
effects they're gonna be worse some of
them are going to be better because
they're actually physically there and
it's not CGI but when they do [ __ ] like
they gotta put lightning in or something
or like the Box illuminates and they
don't use actual light and they just get
some guy in there to draw with a crayon
it's gonna look terrible so granted take
that aside because that was just what
the technology was up to in 1987.
the movie was completely different than
the Remake all right and I don't even
know if it was technically a remake but
the movie was completely different
number one and number two
um
it really put Clive Barker on the map
like Clive Barker put Hellraiser out and
then became he was I guess an author and
then made Hellraiser and then became a
[ __ ] filmmaker
and uh it was way more about SNM
and kinky [ __ ] and also Gore and it was
way different and I guess I I it's one
of those movies I can't even tell if I
liked or not because I'm not in 1987 you
know I guess these movies are okay right
like if you go back and watch Freddy
Krueger now in the first one or like
Jason Voorhees or any of these they're
all just so bad
it's so hard it's like watching [ __ ]
Laurel and Hardy and trying to get a
cackle it's like yeah then pushing the
piano up the stairs was funny in 1902.
or if you're [ __ ] two and a half you
know Calvin laughs at the big wide
one-word purple people eater but I'm
like I'm 42 dude
I don't know man I suggest you watch it
on Hulu and then maybe go watch it with
me man I should do these watch parties
on Twitch is what I should do honestly
but whatever man I'm taking my pure
Spectrum gummies my CBD shits
right now dude with you because I
respect you got a yellow one dude I love
these and uh you can go if you're a CBG
guy
click on the show description
and then type in congrats you get 10 off
of your
gummies
I eat them and I just go oh
and um it's good Calvin has diarrhea
speaking of the cabin has diarrhea dude
and he [ __ ] himself four times and we
cleaned it up and it's all good
he rose with the punches man
imagine just having imagine just like
isn't it crazy
like babies just [ __ ] all the time
from jump in their diapers and they
don't really question it and then one
day you gotta tell them like yo you
gotta use the potty
and they're like but this is a part of
me
you know
what are you doing holding me over the
toilet and letting me release some of
myself into it then what do we do flush
it no that's terrifying that's basically
how razor in the toilet
I can't do that
and I get it dude but he's just [ __ ]
himself every day we [ __ ] ourselves
every day for [ __ ] years all of us
and then
and then we just use potties
I guess it's gross because it smells
[ __ ] bad but imagine
like
finally starting to question that as a
two-year-old you're like hey wait a sec
where's all this [ __ ] coming from
you don't know it's food
and then knowing
and then thinking like wow
a greater
like
something greater than myself has really
kind of fooled me a diaper is a bit of a
[ __ ] invention to be honest
like it's 2022.
hey Huggies
get it together
you know Huggies been Huggies for
decades hey Pampers get it together
you're still [ __ ] all over like get
a [ __ ] thing where a pill you could
take where the you know what I mean
where it just evaporates
if you have a [ __ ] kidney stone you
they shoot sonic waves into your kidney
and it disperses the [ __ ] kidney
stone why can't they do that with [ __ ]
instead you just and Huggies is like yo
we figured there man
talking to Kristen the other day and
she's watching a makeup tutorial and
she's [ __ ] painting watching a makeup
tutorial and I'm like you're 30. you've
been doing makeup for over a decade
don't you know how to do it why do you
watch your tutorials as well and she
says because new stuff's always coming
out and I said what do you mean new
techniques and she says yes but also new
makeup and I said is it makeup makeup
and she was like well no because
sometimes it's different I'm like the
technology and the makeup and she's like
yeah and then you have to reapply it in
different [ __ ] and I'm like if they're
doing that with makeup I can't Huggies
do it
you still got [ __ ] three-year-olds
[ __ ] themselves
give me a pill
I don't want to change a diaper I don't
want to change a diaper
I'm tired of shooting in my pants make
it disperse please
I just wanna toot and fart
every time Calvin too it's did you toot
no did you toot yes every time dude why
no first you're not gonna put one over
on me dude I'm me I'm your dad I know
tune I've been tooting man I I still do
it more than you dude
foreign
is what it is dude in Peoria
I like to do it like that like in Peoria
and New York they keep it the same [ __ ]
dude I don't break it up I keep it the
same
[ __ ] [ __ ] out there breaking it up
I put a sign up right in the front
window advertisement read a different
window and all of a sudden success
coming out of the blue that's [ __ ]
Little Shop of Horrors too I bet you
didn't know I'd [ __ ] oops upside your
head although I know so much [ __ ] about
musicals dude and I love musicals and I
go to a musicals and when I go to
musicals every [ __ ] musical I see the
first minute as soon as it starts I
[ __ ] tear up because I don't deal
with my emotions
you God crit too much Sensations I cried
boot dude I'm basically a center bite
what are we gonna do man too many
Sensations he cries man
foreign
that was just a volume test but it kind
of worked
um every musical I've ever seen I cried
in the first minute except cats because
cats [ __ ] sucks dude it absolutely
sucks dude cats sucks dude they made it
in the 70s and we're still gonna act
like this [ __ ] is nice
I went all the way down to the [ __ ]
office in downtown and I see adults
prancing around uh with [ __ ] feline
[ __ ] a paint like you know
and they're talking about the jellicle
[ __ ] like you're making [ __ ] up dude
sickly I'm jealous
I wish I could make a musical and have a
language of my own I'm secretly secretly
jealous
but he's got the podcast and I'll tell
you it goes out to a lot more people
than it does when the [ __ ] off and
almost how much does the amundsen said
fifteen hundred three thousand oh the
[ __ ] podcast gets 100K videos in a
[ __ ] few days
um so anyway you know it is what it is
and uh that whatever dude I you know
it's like I'm not that I'm not I'm not
the kind of guy that [ __ ] brags and
[ __ ] but it's like
um
just trying to stack this paper dude you
know stack that skrilla stack that
[ __ ] cheddar stack that absolute good
stack the [ __ ] monster
that's me stacking my monster running on
um like And subscribe to the goddamn
super cult Channel they won't [ __ ] dude
they're [ __ ] with me man
anytime someone subscribes YouTube goes
and takes a subscriber off I'm telling
you it happens go check if you're
subscribed actually we've been sitting
at 596
000 subscribers for six months that's
weird put it on Unsolved Mysteries put
it on Ripley's Believe It or Not have
Dean Kane do a [ __ ] monologue about
it and then cut to some clips
it's a conspiracy make a six-part
documentary about it on Netflix
something's going on under the covers
because we've just been tried and true
being the babies and trying to start
this cult
from
jump
so subscribe babies
um
look at this [ __ ] the the woman that man
ring cameras are [ __ ] recording all
sorts of [ __ ] I swear to God sooner or
later there's going to be like oh a ring
cam we got we we found out who actually
shot JFK how ring cameras
oh dude you think ring cameras aren't
going to catch Bigfoot you're wrong bro
stop lying here look at what this one's
caught in the ring cameras
a deer shows up
hey that lady go away one baby
okay so listen man
a [ __ ] deer with horns came out when
the woman was trying to leave and go to
the car she stopped
and looked at the deer for way too long
and chilled like she was gonna like talk
to it like she was like Eddie Murphy and
do Dr Dolittle and then
she went back inside too late and by
that I mean that gave the dog enough
time to run out and go to the deer and
the deer tried to spear the [ __ ] dog
and then the dog went under the [ __ ]
car in safety in defense and then the
lady took the purse and smacked the deer
now look don't do that lady you're
making it worse you made it worse when
you took too long to go into the door
you made it worse when you tried to
[ __ ] attack the deer because the dog
was safe and now you're gonna get
speared and now your husband's gonna get
speared and now your car is going to get
demolished and now your dogs are going
to get trampled on okay
let's watch the rest of this
for Dad help that's awesome [ __ ] yeah
dude that guy's a hero
Jesus Christ nature
she's screaming and nothing's out she's
screaming by herself nothing's happening
look this would be neat right here
that's me right there
but get the key and
click it that's me
why don't you go in and get the key and
click it did you bring it out anyway you
don't bring it out right look this I'm
gonna pretend like I'm in here this is
this is okay say I'm right behind her
this is how I would be right here this
is me oh my god oh [ __ ] get inside get
inside why are you standing there get
inside get inside God damn it okay
you're waiting too long another dog side
all right leave the dog there no don't
[ __ ] God damn I just got you that
purse
I got this okay all right all right all
right this is exactly everything I've
been saying I would be saying move it
hey hey hey hey Dad Dad come here don't
go that way hey everything's fine
everything's fine just get back inside
you don't need to scream the deer's not
doing anything to you get back inside
get back inside good all right stay
there stay there stop you're in my ear
all right go in and get the [ __ ] key
you should have had it anyway if you
came out
and by the way you notice I'm not saying
[ __ ] to the dogs
because this has got to stop
the dogs what happens to the dog that's
the thing
and I know I'm gonna come off heartless
as this but dude my dogs are their own
people all right so if if they run out
into the yard and see a bear and then
the dogs get closer
that's that ass dog
all right
do I run after you hey
Butters you're your own person
you want to shake hands with death
have a good dude
sometimes Bears need lunch you
understand and if you're gonna go be
your own person and not gonna lit hey
Butters get in you don't you get you
take steps towards the bear all right
you be your own person all right because
I'm not coming to your [ __ ] rescue
that's me
and and and then if if the the dog gets
eaten you're so much your own person I
go right to anger I don't even get sad
for you I'm angry now because you [ __ ]
my life up now I got to think about you
now you're just a memory
okay
Bud you're gonna run out and try to
[ __ ] prance with a deer dude then
you're your own person baby the dog
calling her the dog baby everything got
so white
the the lady stopped thought she could
[ __ ] you know what I mean Crocodile
Dundee it into submission
and then ran out and then the dog ran
out the little [ __ ] ass dog and then
did we find out the dog's name is baby
and then the dad comes out in a red
flannel and then the lady didn't unlock
the car dude no Street smarts I guess we
should say wood smarts but man unlock
the [ __ ] car I know though [ __ ] goes
down and you don't really have time to
think about it
that's why I walk into every room like
goddamn Liam Neeson do it where are the
exits where are the exits and let me
just take a [ __ ] glance at all these
people's faces
because you never know when some shit's
going to go down
uh uh yeah dude what a crazy [ __ ]
thing to have happen a deer just [ __ ]
straight up trying to kill their dog
I can't watch that nature [ __ ] I mean
this one was fine but I can't watch that
nature [ __ ]
um
I guess Elon now is going to be doing
Twitter congratulations
um this is hilarious though I mean kind
of sad but the iPhone 14 keeps calling
9-1-1 on roller coasters
the iPhone's 14's new crash detection
feature apparently detects thrill rides
too oh so if you get in a car accident
it's supposed to [ __ ] call something
I just run real what if you run real
fast and then trip
just oh 911 shows up at the outside of a
cafe you're eating you're in the middle
of your food and you're just like what
and he goes all right it's got a script
on my elbow iPhone 14's new crash
detection feature which is supposed to
alert but man imagine how many 911 calls
you get with the first time they must
have thought holy [ __ ] a [ __ ] roller
coaster exploded the iPhone 14's new
crack detection feature which is
supposed to alert authorities when it
detects you've been in a car accident
has an unexpected side effect it dials
9-1-1 on roller coasters and uh
according to a report from The Wall
Street Journal and also the text also
calls 911 when you're watching Jason's
day at the movies no I added that part
um
wow
dude at least the cops when they show up
they could just go on rides afterwards
oh all is good you know what I'm gonna
get some cotton candy
you got
uh Jerry you want some [ __ ] you want
corn nuts I'm gonna get a churro they
everyone's fine it's that stupid [ __ ]
thing iPhone does he's so mad Apple
rolled out crash detection with his new
iPhone 14 Watch series eight uh last
month equipping with
devices is a gyroscopic sensor and a
high G why how do they not think of this
you know how is there not one dork that
was like What if they go on roller
coasters
oh yeah and you got to dismiss it within
20 seconds and they're all [ __ ] tied
in upside down on Batman the ride
when it claws when it calls law
enforcement it will play an audio
message that alerts authorities you've
been in a crash and also provides them
with your location an Apple Watch with
crash detection can only notify
authorities if you have your iPhone with
you or if it's connected to a mobile
network or Wi-Fi
in the meantime [ __ ] people to show
these law enforcement showing up to the
roller coasters and people are just
getting [ __ ] killed
because people are
because they're they're not being called
for the people that are getting killed
they're getting called for the roller
coaster
um
wow
wow that's pretty wild
I bet I could get it to go myself just
standing there
that's gonna be my closer
um
dude did you guys see the [ __ ]
girl who got
a beer thrown at her on um
at like the Vinnie's Comedy Club what
the hell was it I don't have a link here
um what
oh you didn't did you Ivan
um she actually it's weird she looks
kind of I don't know how long she's been
doing stand up
um are you adding the link
I I don't know how long she's been doing
stand up she seems a little bit up look
and no matter how I it takes like 20 or
15 years or 15 years to get the
confidence of like I was talking to
somebody
like when the [ __ ] pops off at comedy
clubs you know because they were asking
me about
like Chris Rock getting attacked and
Dave Chappelle getting attacked and
they're like are you scared and I'm like
like a people like rushing the stage and
like hitting you or whatever the [ __ ] or
anything and I was like I don't know I
mean my crowds are [ __ ] awesome
uh and they're all there and dialed in
and
um
and uh I was talking about it
and it takes 15 years to just kind of
have the confidence to deal with like
true hecklers
um did you put it on here is it here
what
oh all right and um yeah here it is and
um
this woman uh is at a comedy club and
she is
doing
um
what do you call it
I don't know if she's doing crowd work
or what but yeah she actually I think
she says here we'll just let's watch the
clip but she
um they she got a beard a stand-up
comedian is being applauded for how
here we go everybody vote for whoever
you want to vote I don't I don't care
who you voted for I'm just happy we're
all here together people are provided
I don't know
yeah so what why does it matter I could
just stop by your jokes you better
provided yeah by the way you're not a
detective like it's very obvious when
someone's making a joke about certain
things that you could tell who they
voted for I could tell by the fact that
you're still talking but nobody
now that is an absolute [ __ ] golden
dude just golden
[Music]
I mean dude that is just an extreme I
mean dude she she didn't even say it
like a Slammer her hand was in her
pocket she was like well I can just tell
I could just tell you know by the way
that you won't stop talking that you're
somebody who voted for Trump and then
you go
and everyone laughed and they were Trump
voters and they still left because they
recognized comedy so [ __ ]
and it's all good dude but
congratulations for that because she
[ __ ] murdered it with that [ __ ] and
uh but she does seem a little um I don't
know what her vibe is or what her thing
is on stage she does seem a little
nervous but also dude when a crowd turns
against you like even the [ __ ] uh you
know I say 15 years but even when the
crowd turns against you even when you're
uh
you know it can be scary at times I've
had some I've had people run up on stage
um but yeah so
they threw a beer hard too
that's [ __ ] up
oh my God somebody yo I'm never coming
back with this group of people ever
again like the guy who is like the fifth
wheel
I didn't even vote for Biden I voted for
Trump but what the [ __ ]
I can't stand how people can't take a
joke about politics
bro
Trump and Biden both deserve to be made
fun of if you don't think that
how are you going to go to a comedy club
they're both [ __ ] ridiculous
in the best ways in the worst ways
they're [ __ ] ridiculous
you if you don't think Trump is funny if
you don't think Biden watching him is
funny
I mean what the [ __ ] then what are we
doing here
who's gonna be the next president I
really wonder if you ask some people
they say Trump I don't even know if it
won the Primary I mean I have no [ __ ]
idea what's going to be happening but uh
you know it's uh whatever it is dude
it's just gonna be great it's gonna be
great you know because times just keep
getting better you know you say that me
but also I will say this did you know
that crime in the 90s was double it is
now dude
like when you go to Oakland you look at
the graphs and I know this because I
watch YouTube videos of cities
and if you do it you will see crime was
crazy bad in the 90s
the 80s people were serial killing and
now there's like by at any given moment
there's 50 serial killers at large in
America how the [ __ ] do I know that
I watch YouTube videos
there's one in Albuquerque right now
oh really yeah why because Albuquerque
because it's a [ __ ]
there's also one in Long Island there's
also one in Alaska apparently people get
murdered in Alaska at an alarming rate
isn't that crazy dude it's one of the
most dangerous places and it's because
they've got 12 cops dude
not because it's necessarily so bad but
because they got 12 cops and the sun
doesn't even come out
you best believe I'd be murdering that
way
for real dude just ask him I'm joining
the eskimos dude
I'm joining the eskimos if I move to
Alaska dude to me that's like prison you
join the gang I'm and all of a sudden
you won't see past my immediate features
dude I'm joining the eskimos and not
only are they teaching me stuff I'm
teaching them stuff too it's a symbiotic
relationship dude and we [ __ ] show up
to like
goings-on and problems and also like
places where there might be conflict and
ask him
AWA
like this dude you dude my pocket and my
[ __ ] furry [ __ ] is so
it's so cinched look this is all you see
is my nose that right there
can barely breathe I pass out a lot too
they're like this they're like what what
happened Chris what happened and they
gotta uncinch it and I go
oh sorry I I have my uh I did it like I
was like Kenny from [ __ ] South Park
come on we have to go
okay okay
here's some salmon belly
[Laughter]
here's some salmon belly do I what do I
do do I eat it no put it in your armpits
for good luck oh really yes and warmth
oh okay I don't know
anyway we've got to go to town hall and
murder no one will catch us
so um
so yeah
so we go to [ __ ] uh so yeah anyways
Alaska but crime has been crime was
terrible the gank I I subscribed to hood
vlogs
better believe it dude and gangsters the
most gangster thing you're probably the
most gangster thing is like Robin and
stealing and shooting [ __ ] but
it's not you know what being the most
gangster [ __ ] is is being the absolute
most positive guy ever being the most
positive guy and loving your kids so
much and still be running the block Like
It's Hot seriously
dude when you watch these Hood Vlogs
there's always like one or two gang
members that's like you know I mean this
is the hood but like I'm always trying
to get up out the hood that's the thing
man like the hood is a mentality and the
hood is a lifestyle and you know I yeah
I I you know it's it's a rough life and
I don't want it for my kids I don't wish
it on anybody I don't wish it on my
worst enemies man but then they always
pepper something in like but if they
come across here and they're not
supposed to I'll kick their [ __ ] ass
and push their way back but I will say
though man like I don't you know I don't
wish this lifestyle in anybody but they
should call us if they're coming across
this block because we'll [ __ ] light
them up like the 4th of July anyway
but they're so positive this is my
daughter you know and you're just
holding the kid what's up
you want to go play in a car okay you
wanna go play in the sprinkler okay
watch out for bullets
but it's so gangster to be so positive
um
yeah
it's crazy to go I want to go to South
Central a little bit and just poke my
head and how wide is that dude how
[ __ ] privileged is that I just want
to check it out
want to drive by in what car I want to
drive by and just [ __ ] see what's up
dude I pretty much pretty much want to
do that
I've been shot at once I've never told
that story on this podcast by the way
I've [ __ ] straight up have been shot
at how crazy is that and I it some
things you just forget for long enough
that they're gone but I've straight up
been shot at
this was probably
15
years ago probably
15 years ago
um I was seeing this girl and she was
like come over I had never been over her
place
um
and she was like
come over and I said okay I'll come over
this time
to this day
I have no idea what area it was in like
like for real I couldn't tell you if it
was Northwest East [ __ ] south or it
could have she it could have been up I
have no idea
and
she's like so it's not the best
neighborhood but park if you can get a
space if not you know they do the whole
thing where it's like I got an extra
spot but I'll have to move and the thing
and the Tandem and you're like all right
I'll just you know I'll find a spot so
what does your boy do your boy Parks
illegally
so I park illegally and only a little
bit illegally like my back [ __ ] bumper
is peeking out with the and hitting the
red
and I'm walking over I can't even
believe how much I don't know where this
was
I wish I knew like did I take the 101 or
the 405 or the 10 and then which way did
I go was it on the way to Barstow like I
have no [ __ ] idea so I'm walking and
I hear
and I'm just I go whoa and I'm like oh
and I don't even register what it even
might be I just
think sounds are happening like I'm 28
and it's not even like oh did something
pop did a tire get flat why are there
two of those and I'm certainly not
thinking oh a gunshot
so I'm like wow what was that and like
that [ __ ] idiot who saw the deer I
just stand
and I'm looking around
and then I hear
Pat
and as I'm like is that good
I get to there
is that
gunshots I get to is that
and I hear
listen
and I go what the [ __ ] was that
and then I go fast walk to where she
lives and she lets me in
and I feel myself saying it's not like I
even decided to say it it's just like
whoops oh oopsie Daisy we're already on
the roller coaster of talking and I
guess this is what we're saying and I
said I I think I just got shot at and as
I say that she says yeah
it's a bad neighborhood but you're all
good just stay here
and I'll never forget this dude
she was awesome and we just hung out for
a little bit and then she you know made
me feel Sensations we'll say for the
niceness of YouTube and she made me feel
Sensations and then I said why are you
so good at that and she said I don't
know I usually
she said I usually date Republicans and
surprises the [ __ ] out of them
that's what you said how my mother
forgot it
but it was [ __ ] crazy dude
I'll just imagine her [ __ ] going to
town in SLC just like whoa whoa whoa
guys are just like whoa whoa whoa whoa
in Provo oh hold on
wait a second I at St George where where
am I
he's just laying it down
[Music]
foreign
yeah so I've been shot at
dude you guys thank you so much I
appreciate you watching and look dude
the tour is up it's locked and loaded
don't push me go on to chrysalia.com and
see all the new cities that I've added
and get your tickets now before the good
seats fill up and some of them are going
to sell out you can go get your CBD
shits at the link below and type in code
congrats and then also get your
crystalline merch to wear at the [ __ ]
shows
and uh chrisley.com sign up for the
patreon if you'd like if not we love you
anyway but like And subscribe dude we're
trying to grow the [ __ ] [ __ ] to at
least 600 000. I've been sitting at
[ __ ] 596 for six months so let's
change that you guys hey guys that's the
episode for YouTube if you want to catch
the raw uncut unedited extra long
version you go on over to the patreon
right now and you can watch that and you
can also watch that for every episode
that comes out and you can also watch
every extra episode we do per month uh
which I now there's like 18 of them so
go sign up for the patreon it's only six
bucks a month and uh you can do that and
you can also watch the other stuff that
we do we post
um this segment called review mode where
I review various different things and
also get a podcast with Kristen on there
so uh yeah enjoy go to patreon.com
crystalia thanks
foreign
[Music]